30 some odd years after Star Wars to do
number seven I felt you know very happy
to be able to continue adding to this
glossary of themes
[Music]
JG did speak to me about the feeling we
would all want to have that this is star
wars all we need is Don Williams and
then it stopped and particularly
connected if we could do the early you
felt
who doesn't have Leia we have han Luke
revisited here there are references to
earlier thematic connections between
characters and music and so on and that
seemed a very natural thing to do and
combine it with no melodic material for
the new characters ray perceived has a
musical grammar that is not heroic in
the sense of a hero seeing
this kind of an adventure theme that
maybe promises more than resolving
itself in the most major triumphant
resolutions
[Music]
we first meters she's been alone she's
with her parents I felt a lot of empathy
for that girl and I think Ray's theme
he's Sevilla straight that
I approach the task of kylo Ren really
just as an extension of Darth Vader in a
way show me again the power of the
doctors and I didn't want to get too
close to it
but if it could convey in a few short
notes as the Imperial March does this
evil power strength threat
[Music]
it needs to be something it will hit you
as accessible right away when in one
take 756 when we recorded the opening
and closing of the very first Star Wars
film I didn't have any idea there would
be a second one none of us had the idea
that we'd ever hear the music again
[Music]
when we played that music with the orcas
or the beginning of the end it was a
celebratory moment for them and for me
in Jersey
it was like visiting an old friend
[Music]
having kept up with in this lon I have
to say that I just feel very grateful
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie so john
williams released this behind the scenes
of the star wars soundtrack the episode
7 soundtrack and it is a really good job
of reminding you how important music is
to star wars i wouldn't say his score
for episode 7 is my favorite Star Wars
score I still think the original trilogy
is my favorite just because it hit me at
the perfect time in my childhood there
used to be like a six-disc or five disc
special edition of all the soundtracks
from the original trilogy and my parents
got it for me on CD when I was a little
kid I think they were the first CDs that
I ever got that I was able to listen to
start to finish without taking a break
if you've ever heard a joke about
someone listening to Pink Floyd or some
other psychedelic music in the dark and
just tripping out the original trilogy
soundtracks are one of the best way to
do that I'm not advocating for the use
of drugs or anything like that but you
get the idea what makes them so
beautiful is that they create this world
of the film just using music it's the
job of the composer John Williams in
this case to create the emotional story
for the film just using music so that
when you're watching the movie you have
context for scenes like when you're
watching ray sit there play with the
x-wing helmet you sense that she's
waiting now you can see it just because
you're watching the movie but the music
tells you that she is longing for
something from the new soundtrack from
the episode 7 soundtrack i would say
raised theme is probably my favorite
song from the original trilogy my
favorite track usually bounces back and
forth between one or two things
depending on what my mood is the
imperial march from Empire Strikes Back
I think the only star wars track that's
more ubiquitous than that is the opening
fanfare the opening title crawl music
but that actually isn't my other
favorite the one that I bounce back and
forth between is the episode for throne
room and credits track it's super
celebratory because they just blew the
Death Star up and they're getting shiny
prizes are all pumping their fists in
the air and there's this driving force
aspect to it that makes you feel like
they're pushing forward into the next
film like the rebellion is marching
forward into the next movie those are
the two tracks that I listen to what I
want to get really pumped up but it
depends on what I'm getting pumped up
for some of my friends who are actual
critics said they didn't like the
episode 7 soundtrack quite as much as
the classic trilogy or even the
soundtrack for the prequel movies I
still like the original trilogy
soundtrack more than the prequels but I
still haven't quite decided if I liked
the episode 7 child track more than the
prequel soundtrack let me know in the
comments
what is your favorite Star Wars music it
could be diegetic music which is music
like the cantina band that happens
inside the films or the soundtrack like
stuff that plays around the film I think
I talked about it in my Easter Egg video
but if you guys don't know who
lin-manuel is he's this really awesome
musician and performer that's mostly
been doing hamilton recently but he also
composed the original song for maz
kanata's cantina so when you see Star
Wars in the band starts playing like
that version of the cantina band it's
kind of like a cantina band scene
lin-manuel composed and performed that
song inside the film it wasn't a John
William song speaking of easter eggs
here's a really cool 124 episode 6
Return of the Jedi John Williams has a
son named Joseph Williams who's also a
musician he wrote the lyrics for max
rebo's band during the lop de next song
so much of the magic of Star Wars owes
to its music and it sounds it's so
unique that's what makes Star Wars Star
Wars really there are three big star
wars sounds it no matter what language
you speak you will instantly associate
with Star Wars one there's the sound of
a lightsaber to the howl of a TIE
fighter and three Darth Vader's
respirator that's actually another good
question for you guys let me know in the
comments what is your favorite Star Wars
sound is it the sound of a lightsaber is
that the sound of Darth Vader's
breathing I feel like they're just a
couple things that everyone has in
common you always know what the sound of
someone popping their lightsaber is and
it means is going down if you guys
are big star wars collectors I don't
collect a lot of toys but I do like to
collect a lot of music they're releasing
the vinyl for episode 7 in another month
or two so it should be coming pretty
soon you can pre-order it but it's
already on Spotify so you can listen to
it for free but if you really want to
spend the money on the awesome vinyl
edition it should be out pretty soon
just to talk about episode 8 1st 2nd
Rian Johnson's been filming they just
started filming that's what I posted
that teaser for the other week but he's
also been doing the funny thing of
posting images from the set like he
posted this console photo here he posted
this camera photo here like is this
technology is this a droid just funny
ways of marketing the film without
actually marketing the film which I'm
totally down for I love his sense of
humor he's one of those directors that's
very open I think JJ Abrams learn to be
a little bit more open when they were
filming episode 7 they tended to keep
things a little closer to the best with
the exception of those omae's videos but
for those of you that are really upset
that we haven't seen a rogue
one trailer yet don't worry I think it's
gonna drop with Captain America Civil
War Disney tends to group their films
together so you know big Marvel film
happening they're gonna put some star
wars with it too if there are any Star
Wars videos that you guys want me to do
just let me know in the comments and
there is a new captain america civil war
that i have for tonight so be sure to
subscribe to get that why you guys wait
for that video to post in case you
haven't seen it i just posted my
deadpool easter egg video last week you
can click here to watch that and you can
click here for that episode eight teaser
video thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight me mini nehe me
[Music]